picture this
you're having a nice relaxing walk on a
private beach without
a care in the world all of a sudden your
foot
drops into a deep and mucky puddle
you struggle to pull your leg out but it
just
won't budge before you know it you're
sinking rapidly
and half of your body is submerged in
cold
wet quicksand the more you struggle
the more you sink talk about a terrible
way to end a vacation
but it doesn't have to be here's how to
survive
falling into quicksand
you've probably seen people up to their
neck in quicksand in the movies but
in real life it's quite rare
if you happen to slip in you'd likely
just sink
halfway most of the time quicksand isn't
actually that deep but it can still be
incredibly dangerous if you're trapped
and there's no one around to help you
you could suffer hypothermia dehydration
or
even suffocation you might also be an
easy target for hungry predators
and if you're close to the water watch
out for the tides coming in or heavy
rainfall
hope you packed a snorkel how could you
stay afloat
in quicksand what signs of quicksand
should you look out for and
could you rescue yourself if you're all
alone
quicksand is found all over the planet
but is most common
near coastal areas marshes and
riverbanks
there's even dry quicksand that can be
found in deserts
unlike mud or regular sand quicksand
is a non-newtonian fluid meaning
it's solid in one state but if anything
agitates it
it quickly turns to liquid causing you
to sink
deeper and deeper so
what should you do in this scenario step
one
stop moving
first things first don't panic and don't
move
calm down and be as still as possible
the more you move the deeper you will
sink
step two lighten the load
if you have any bags jackets or
anything heavy on you take them off and
throw them away
i'm sorry but it's you or the bling
less weight means you'll sink less
quickly
step three grab on to something
if you are with a friend grab their hand
or grab hold of a tree branch nearby
put as much weight as you can on the
object you're holding on to
this will slow down the sinking process
and help you stay afloat
step four lean back and wiggle your feet
leaning back will increase your surface
area making it harder for you to sink
wiggling your feet will help liquefy the
sand and
help you free your legs once they're
free
start paddling backwards with your arms
to move yourself to solid ground
if your arms are stuck try rolling your
body instead
step five call for help
if all else fails your voice might be
the only thing that can save you
call for help and if you can reach your
phone dial 9-1-1
immediately you could suffocate if
you're stuck in there for too long
step 6 breathe deeply
this will make your body more buoyant
try to meditate and
focus on your breath it's time to put
those yoga classes to good use
if you're lucky someone will come to the
rescue but
they need to be extra careful about
pulling you out
they could rip you in half if they pull
too hard
with quicksand being two times denser
than humans
its suction is incredibly strong
the weight of the sand can also damage
your nerves and muscles
this is called crush syndrome and can
lead to the release of compounds that
can harm your kidneys
so it's best to try and get your legs
free and stay flat
this will alleviate pressure on your
muscles and organs
and let you safely return to the surface
dying from quicksand isn't common but it
can
still happen next time you're traveling
educate yourself ahead of time about the
dangers and risks in the surrounding
area
quicksand could be the least of your
problems
especially if you're lost in the amazon
jungle
in which case if you want to stay alive
keep watching
how to survive